ellie can you please mute
your screen ellie smith yep nobody
thank you
i muted
just don't make sure you don't change
something else because she's sitting
there
sonia if you let us know when we're live
streaming please
hello
chairman we're live thank you very much
good morning my name is council laureen
shaw
and i'm the chairman of the of the
licensing and appeals committee for
today's meeting
my fellow committee members all
councillor david merrick
and councillor mike carter the committee
clerk is sonya worthington
principal democratic and corporate
service officer
the legal advisor today is rebecca hurst
senior solicitor
the purpose of the hearing is to
consider
an application for a review of the
premises
license regarding to the premises known
as crafty casks
33 eastwood road raleigh please
can anyone everyone use their microphone
when speaking and mute
them when they are not required to speak
please ensure
also that you are following the council
procedure on remote
meetings you will all have an
opportunity to speak
and ask questions please only speak when
it is your turn
please can the council's license officer
introduce himself
good morning i'm stephen greener i'm the
principal licensing officer
thank you steve could the applicant
ins uh please introduce himself and do
you propose to call and
any witnesses
that me it is okay
okay uh chairman uh councillor mike
wilkinson ward councillor for
uh whitney ward in which the premise is
situated um
yes i do propose um to
bring forward a live witness who is
larissa eid a resident
in the flats directly above uh the
premises we're discussing today
thank you could the council's
environmental health officer introduce
yourself do you propose to call any
witnesses please
uh no good morning my name is von
sheridan rocha district council
environmental health
also present with me today is my
colleague
james [ __ ] from environmental health as
well
thank you could the the interested
parties introduce themselves
hello my name's ellie ellie smith um and
i live at 31c
eastwood road
okay are there any other interesting
pasties
wishing to speak
no thank you sonia have all the parties
receive the agenda and report for
today's hearing
i can't see any hands saying no before
we begin i
understand there is an application to
extend time from the environmental
health officer
ms sheridan um to apply and um
sorry i will start that again i've read
that wrong before we begin i understand
there is an
application to extend time from the
environmental health officer
ms sheridan would you like to apply for
this extension
uh yes please it's um in regards to um
providing some context in regards to the
cctv
um rebecca hurst could you advise please
you're on mute rebecca yes okay um
yes in relation to the cctv evidence um
i understand that the cctv was part of
the environmental health office's case
and cctv stills have been
provided within that bundle it's now the
case that the
footage itself has been um
amended so that it is now in a viewable
format
for the committee hearing today
so the the evidence as i understand it
is not
new evidence being presented today it
has always been part of the
environmental health case
um nonetheless the footage is
approximately 21 minutes long is that
correct um i'll ask the sheraton to
confirm
yes that's correct um now ordinarily we
would simply take that cctv footage um
separately but it's for you
members to determine whether you wish to
extend
the time for miss sheridan's
representations
in order to allow her to provide a
commentary
on that footage what you may want to
take into consideration
also is the views of mr smith and i
think
mr smith may have been missed on the
introductions
so you can you can ask him if he is
happy as the license holder
i understand a copy of the cctv has been
provided to him to review
um as it forms the the evidence in the
environmental health
report but it would also be for the
license holder to
be able to respond but i would
advise that you do allow an extension
for the cctv
to be shown it's a matter for the
committee to determine
but it's also a matter within your gift
as to whether you wish that to be
with a commentary or effectively for it
to be agreed
as if read because that will affect when
it can be shown
during the course of these
of this hearing um so i would suggest
chair that you consider that point first
of all now i can perhaps address you on
when the
when the footage should be shown okay
speak to mr smith yeah okay other
committee members
um do we want to have this ctv shown and
do we want commentary please
yeah i'm happy for it to be shown but um
commentaries
is not no
sorry counselor mike carter you lost i
lost the
little bit last bit ah yeah no
commentary for me thank you
thank you council david merrick
okay so it's i know i agree that we
should have the
cctv but no commentary thank you
i i'm just going to interject their
chair if if i may
um can i just ask that you clarify with
mr smith
if he is content with that and if miss
sheridan is content with that
also okay um
as you uh heard from our league or about
mr smith and miss sheridan are you
content with
just seeing the cctv or would you like
it with dialogue please
um i'm happy for the cctv to be shown
without the commentary
i'm happy too and obviously if you
require clarification
i can provide it at that stage thank you
very much
so um chair but for a
procedural point i would then suggest
that the comment that the cctv be shown
at the end of the hearing that's a
practical point that i know you're going
to be
addressing because it cannot be live
streamed
on youtube so that part of the hearing
will have to
take place without the live streaming
and therefore it may be appropriate
given that the parties have agreed that
it just be shown
um that it could be shown after the
closing statements are made
yes i'm happy with that i think that's a
i will go through that as
on the clarification thank you very much
um now we've clarified that additionally
i would like to draw your attention to
the procedure on item three of the
agenda
it has been brought to the committee's
attention by our legal adviser
that they ordered the presentations at
1.3 and 1.4 ought to be amended
for the premises review hearing
therefore the order of for parties to
make their
submissions will be as follows
licensing officer mr greener then
applicant
councillor wilkinson responsible
authority
that being the environmental health ms
sheridan
interested passes missed license holder
mr smith
the time of the time limit of 15 minutes
per party remains in place
15 minutes is a total time of
all interested parties and will be
apportioned between them
freeze if all parties could have men cut
their copy of the procedure as follows
part three is amended to read applicant
submissions and part
six is amended to read license hold
license holder submissions
and as we have agreed there we have will
be 25 minutes for revenge
for environmental health to produce the
cc
footage without commentary
and this will be played at the end
while the meeting is held in public
there is a difference between showing
such evidence within a public building
and streaming over the internet
as the footage contains images of
members of the public
this part of the hearing will not be
streamed to
will not be screened to avoid potential
breaches of the gtpr
to ensure the smooth running of this
hearing the ctt
footage will be taken out of order wrong
rather than
being presented at the time of the
representations from
environmental health
mr greener will you please present your
reports
thank you thank you very much with
permission from the committee if it's
okay i won't go through the full report
because obviously it has been already
written down
but what might be useful for all parties
that are listening
um is to actually go through the process
of how we've actually got to today
and also as well the key sort of bullet
points that would be brought to the
attention of the members
for their consideration it's not
obviously to
determine the outcome of the
application but to certainly point out
some key bullet points
obviously i have them um sort of marked
on my sheet of paper so i'm not
expecting everyone to follow them as
quickly as
myself going through them but i think it
will be more beneficial to
as there's quite a lot of documentation
there to sort of go
down through the the main sort of facts
um to help
the committee in making a decision
therefore an application to review the
license is under section 51
based on the licensing objectives and a
review was submitted
on the 28th of august 2020
in real life excuse me steve sorry to
button
um ellie can you actually be seen on the
screen because we can't actually see you
and i do apologize uh councillor
wilkinson i do realize you have a
question and once steve has actually
finished
i will come back to you i do apologize
it's not a question
it was just to point out what rebecca
already said which was you missed
mr smith off the initial introductions
that's what it was thank you thank you
councillor wilkinson sorry steve
no problem um an application was
received
also so we've got a problem on our live
moments
okay i've taken off good phones is that
better
is that better is for me council america
is that better for you
council and eric can you hear it now
no no no
jeff i may i think it's actually
councilman merrick's connection as
opposed to because council america is
very distorted to me but steve
is clear are you and everybody else
um councillor merrick can i please
suggest that you might want to
exit the meeting and rejoin um and we
will
we will wait until such time as you do
that
quietly for a few please and i'll get
back as quick as i can
yes we thank you councillor and can i
advise everyone on this
um meeting to please stay still because
you are being streamed
live on youtube and this is a
professional
application and meeting and we need to
be shown that we are professional thank
you
okay
chairman rebecca's got her hand up
thank you i can't sorry i can't see
these so i do apologize
um oh he's gone
thanks rebecca have you got your hand up
yes i had but i'm not sure if i had my
electronic hand up um just just
whilst councillor americas is rejoining
um it has been raised by councillor
wilkinson that mr smith
um didn't formally introduce himself at
the beginning
so perhaps it might be an idea to take
this moment
when council america rejoins to ask mr
smith to
formally identify himself and and one
point that i missed
on the cctv um was just
addressing councillor wilkinson on that
point
also um as the applicant um
so chair may i suggest respectfully that
that
when mr when council america re enters
that we just addressed those
housekeeping points and then perhaps ask
mr greener to
start a game with his report yeah so
what did
i understand mr smith what what about
the
cctv cctv i i
suggested that you just check with both
the
authority and the um and the license
holder
but i i i negated to to include the
applicant in that which is council
wilkinson just to check that he was
happy
on the cctv being played in that manner
also yeah i do apologize
right i think that was my error so my
apologies there
sorry can i talk please
hello please hello yes sorry i was told
that i was only going to be in here 10
minutes
so and um i have to work so i don't
really know what's going on
sorry well at the moment one of our
counselors who is on the appeals
um we're having difficulty with his
connection
um and he can't hear anyone and unless
he can hear
um we can't make any decisions right
we're just waiting for him to come back
in
and then it will start but it will be
longer than 10 minutes you'll be in here
for
okay but i mean i'm at a really
important client's house at the moment
and i can't be set on the phone so
can i come back in when it's my turn to
speak or
what's your view on that um please
rebecca
can i take advice on that please
uh yeah but perhaps if i can just send a
a message to you on that quickly and we
we just have a moment
and i will come back to you okay thank
you
thing is
counselor sure are you happy for me to
to address you
yes i am thank you yes and um
i'm not sure that that's going to be
permissible
um and i will happily also invite
uh mr greener to provide his view
necessary but as an interested party
um the miss smithy you are here present
as
a a party to the proceedings and should
be here throughout
um the hearing um so that that i think
is
is an issue um that we cannot have
parties simply
coming in and out of the hearing um
but i'm happy to also raise that point
with mr garina
in case he has an alternate view
your view mr greener please yes my
understanding of the hearings
regulations
is that um all parties should be present
if they wish
and make representation obviously we
have got a written statement already
from um ms smith already that we could
accept
um as her evidence however if there's
any additional
information that she wishes to give she
would have to give that orally
during the actual hearing thank you
so um ms smith i'm afraid if you come
out of this
meeting you will not be allowed to come
back in
i'm not sure she's listening to jim yeah
miss smith
uh can you hear me no i am listening
i am listening sorry i don't get all
this soon i didn't press the button
i said yeah that's why i can stay in you
can stay
thank you very much
is mr as councillor merrick managed to
get back in
sonia could i ask if you could ring
david merrick councillor merrick to see
if he's got a problem
thank you
this
hello we we are seeing um council david
merrick seems to be having problems
um coming back into this uh meeting i
will suggest that we adjourn for 15
minutes
um and then come back so i do apologize
but this is the best